[Musique]
tous ces tests sont terminés j'ai moins
confiance au total dix mois ce type et
je dois beaucoup à ton père et je lui ai
promis de te ramener chez toi avant
minuit alors on y va
nous n'avons pas encore toutes les
réponses concernant les événements
survenus à moscou il ya deux ans mais
aujourd'hui nous mettons tous nos
efforts en commun pour s'assurer
qu'aucun objet d'identifier ne puisse
plus jamais arriver sur notre planète
le prodigieux j'habite à coucher nous à
votre adresse complète mon adresse
complète super constellation de la
vierge galaxie voisine de la voie lactée
bras d'orion système solaire planète
terre tu as tort s'il te plaît ne
résiste pas je ne veux pas te faire du
mal elle est dans une voiture avec un
homme rare ils sont revenus
ioulia tué en danger maintenant
je te croyais mort
tu dois d'en voler le plus vite possible
gilles a donné l'ordre de tirer ou
n'avez pas la parole général est notre
seule clé d'accès à ces technologies
ma vie est en danger elle n'est plus
comme chou ses nouveaux pouvoirs peuvent
être une menace pour tout le monde
revenir chez toi mais elle doit être
éliminé il va peut être mourir à cause
de toi
qu'est ce que vous préférez
le monde ma fille alors toi tu gagnes
[Musique]
nous sommes des êtres humains et nous
devons nous sauver les uns les autres
par tous les moyens
mais moi c'est quelle planète que tu
défendes